it's been one stumble after another for
President Biden's five-day overseas trip
to Nato but boy did he just really end
it in a pretty peculiar way tape of the
president nibbling at the shoulder of a
frightened little girl look at that has
everyone on media cringing but it comes
amid a new report on how the president's
Antics have got Democrats worried top
donors are said to be quietly looking
for a replacement candidate Brian Newsom
they're worried over the slow pace of
Joe's campaign and how he hasn't even
set up a campaign headquarters yet but
there's one Democrat candidate who isn't
slowing down RFK Jr talking to Fox and
Friends this morning about polarization
in America
they're tired of the polarization
they're tired of the anger try to focus
on the values that Americans share with
each other Republicans and Democrats
rather than focusing on those issues
that are keeping us all apart the
polarization is so toxic it's so
venomous and it's I think it's more
dangerous than any time since the
American Civil Wars and we have to start
talking to each other while RFK pushes
Unity the media continues to divide us
listen to the deplorable thing in MSNBC
guest said about pro-trump Americans
one of the things that's disturbing is I
guess this is working with a portion of
the American people and that for me is
just kind of hard to take and so what
exactly is this hold that trumpism has
on some portion of the American people
that their representatives are coming to
Washington and acting amok in this way
as Mika said whether it's you know
ignorance
um stupidity or or graft you know
something more nefarious I don't know
hmm pretty sure that was the same lady
who was upset by the American flags but
regardless we'll set that aside Jesse
what do you make of the furtive Tech
sideline events emails phone calls to
prospective candidates from Big
Democrats saying like hey Joe's not
really running well the smart money is
hedging right now because if you have a
lot of dough would you just plow it all
into the Biden campaign no you'd look
for an alternative because he's not
campaigning Jesse Waters prime time has
more staff than Joe Biden's re-election
he also has done one event that he
didn't pay for and he underperformed in
his fundraising
vis-a-vis Barack Obama and he doesn't
even have a campaign headquarters he
doesn't even have a campaign Finance
chairman and the last time I saw the guy
he was laying back like this glistening
in the sun with his eyes closed on the
beach that doesn't look like someone's
running for reelection and then he's
going to this pretend you're a baby
and then he said the makeup the sniff
look at your jacket if you're a donor
send that to the dry cleaner if you're a
donor and I do that to my child in the
privacy of my own home I don't do it to
a random Finnish baby in the middle of
in the middle of Europe yeah in the
middle of year I mean I think we should
go to our resident child sniffer on that
one Greg Gutfeld what does that mean hey
you hit kill me no uh uh yeah he put the
hell in Helsinki the baby may be from
Finland but Joe Biden is finished oh how
do you like that for a little word play
I love it yeah it's just I don't see how
this can keep going on it's embarrassing
he's not quietly quitting he's you know
quietly dead I mean he hasn't done
anything he doesn't know where he is and
he and
I don't trust people that can't like
show any restraint you know this guy
he's it's it's creepy right I mean it's
like I get it when people talk about
kids and puppies like oh you just want
to eat them up you're not supposed to
you can say oh I just wanna you don't
actually do that men don't usually do
that it's usually the women oh what a
cute baby now remember I want to just
point out
um Mary gay what's interesting about her
commentary is that she says that people
are stupid right this is the woman who
took Bloomberg's 500 million dollar
presidential campaign War chest and said
that if you you could have taken that
and given a million dollars to all of
the 370 million Americans quite possibly
one of the dumbest things that's ever
been said on television do you guys
remember that with Brian Williams
she cannot tell people they're stupid
she's lost that right right she can no
longer say that Harold I could ask you
about the president eating a child's
shoulder but I won't do that to you on a
Friday afternoon instead I will ask you
about his fundraising 77 million but
Trump in the same period had a hundred
million Obama north of 80 million so
it's kind of lackluster
look I think when you run for
re-election uh for president democrat or
republican you've got to do two things
one you gotta forcefully lay out what
you've done the last four years and then
Advocate on behalf of yourself and your
team as to why you need another four
years to build on that success and
ordinarily the two things that underline
or animate that are economic success
economy the market president Trump I
thought rightly talked about the success
of the stock market being an indicator
of how well things are going our economy
has proved to be pretty resilient and
the stock market has proved to be pretty
resilient so he will talk about that I
differ with you on the thing with the
kid there I didn't I had not seen that
until until now I read that read the
script beforehand but I thought he had a
decent time in Helsinki in the sense
that Sweden joins NATO NATO reiterated
its commitment to as you put it back up
there NATO reiterated its commitment to
Ukraine we made clear that Ukraine would
find its win in NATO after we find some
resolution to Russia the Russia
Ukrainian issue because we don't want
immediately once they join us to be War
there so I actually thought it was a
decent week from I call balls and
Strikes here on this show about him and
but I thought he had to do that
I've copyrighted but I think that I
think he actually had a better week uh
than than perhaps some are giving him
credit for now having said that RFK Jr
the things he's talking about are things
that Democrats they're on Democrats mind
so it'll be interesting to see how
President Biden begins to incorporate
some of that narrative into his campaign
narrative you know and I don't know how
this foreign trip is going to move
voters I don't think it will Emily but
what could move voters the media totally
deriding Trump supporters the same way
they did last time around in 2016. what
happened there great this is a media
that as you pointed out we talked about
this says that the American flag flying
from a truck is offensive in fact it's a
security threat that by virtue of your
presence if you are a patriot if you
dare to fly the flag from your home if
you vote in a certain way you are the
threat this is exactly why Americans
feel totally alienated and unseen in
that that's why Trump resonated with so
many people obviously and think about
all those figureheads you know the now
unemployed Don Lemon who made fun of
people from the South voting for
president Trump Jake Tapper who said
Navy Biden's mom well you know she's
she's been you know associated with
people on the right so there's that what
does that mean that if I vote
conservative I'm not befitting to be a
mother is that what that comment made
they're Mika and Mara gay who say it's
ignorant and the like what is ignorant
about policies that result in limited
government and higher unemployment rates
in thriving of an economy in the things
that people care about including for
example the multifaceted Hispanic
population that for some reason Biden
thinks by putting out a commercial in
six different Hispanic accents that that
will somehow attract a very diverse
population that cares first and foremost
about the economy and safety and
education and Lawn crime and for all
those reasons that's why they are
flocking to the GOP policies but I guess
to those media figureheads they just
call it trumpism and they call it a
security threat well the nibbling
president is off to a Beachside vacation
so stay clear kids fastest is up next
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else